>>> TONIGHT, A CNN EXCLUSIVE.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT NOW
ASKING A FEDERAL JUDGE TO FORCE
TWO TOP LAWYERS FROM DONALD
TRUMP'S WHITE HOUSE TO TESTIFY
ABOUT CONVERSATIONS WITH HIM.
THOSE LAWYERS ARE FORMER WHITE
HOUSE COUNSEL PAT CIPOLLONE AND
PATRICK PHILBIN.
TRUMP WAGED A SECRET COURT FIGHT
TO BLOCK FORMER ADVISERS FROM
TESTIFYING BEFORE A FEDERAL
GRAND JURY INVESTIGATING THE
EVENTS OF JANUARY 6th.
OUR SENIOR JUSTICE CORRESPONDENT
EVAN PEREZ IS OUT FRONT.
EVAN, THIS COULD, I THINK, HAVE
A MAJOR IMPACT ON THE
INVESTIGATION IF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT SUCCEEDS AND GETS
THESE FORMER IT TRUMP LAWYERS TO
TESTIFY, RIGHT?
>> RIGHT.
IT REALLY DOES HAVE THE
POSSIBILITY OF GETTING
PROSECUTORS INTO THE INNER
CIRCLE OF DONALD TRUMP AND HIS
WHITE HOUSE.
PAT CIPOLLONE WAS THE FORMER
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL.
PATRICK PHILBIN WAS HIS DEPUTY.
AND THEY WERE THERE DURING SOME
OF THESE CONVERSATIONS AS THE
FORMER PRESIDENT WAS TRYING TO
IMPEDE THE TRANSFER OF POWER IN
2020, WHICH IS AFTER THE 2020
ELECTION, WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT
THE PROSECUTORS OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ARE INVESTIGATING.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SO FAR
HAS BEEN WINNING THESE SECRET
PROCEEDINGS THAT ARE GOING ON AT
THE COURTHOUSE HERE IN
WASHINGTON.
THEY GOT GREG JACOB AND MARK
SHORT, FORMER AIDES TO THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT PENCE TO
COME BACK IN AND ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
THESE ARE VERY, VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS ABOUT CONVERSATIONS
THAT THEY HAD WITH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
SO, THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
WINNING THESE FIGHTS DOES BODE
WELL FOR THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
AS THEY TRY TO GET THE COMPELLED
TESTIMONY OF CIPOLLONE AND
PHILBIN.
>> EVAN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WANT TO GO NOW TO THE
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW PROFESSOR AT
HARVARD LAW SCHOOL, WHO ALSO
CONSULTED HOUSE DEMOCRATS FOR
THE IMPEACHMENT OF THEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SO, PROFESSOR, WHAT DOES IT MEAN
FOR DONALD TRUMP IF THE DOJ
SUCCEEDS HERE AND GETS IN THIS
INNER CIRCLE, THE PAT CIPOLLONE
AND PAT PHILBIN'S TESTIMONY?
>> IT MEANS HE'S IN DEEP
TROUBLE.
THERE'S NO REASON THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT SHOULD NOT SUCCEED.
WHEN A GRAND JURY DEMANDS THE
TESTIMONY OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
FIRST-HAND KNOWLEDGE OF SOMEONE
WHO APPEARS TO HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN AN INSURRECTION AND
A SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY.
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO GET THAT
INFORMATION.
IF THERE WERE AN EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE FOR A FORMER
PRESIDENT, AND THAT'S DOUBTFUL,
IT WOULD BE OVERCOME BY THE
CONTEXT.
THE INFORMATION IS NEEDED FOR A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
IT WAS UNANIMOUS IN THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT IN BOTH CASES
WHERE THE ISSUE AROSE THAT THE
NEED FOR INFORMATION IN A
CRIMINAL PROCEEDING TRUMPS, NO
PUN INTENDED, ANY EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
SO THERE IS NO BASIS FOR THEM TO
RESIST THE ORDER THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO GET FROM THE DEPARTMENT
MOTION WITH THE COURT.
AND THERE'S NO REASON FOR THE
COURT TO DENY THAT MOTION.
>> SO, OBVIOUSLY THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT.
THERE IS ALSO WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THE GRAND JURY INVESTIGATION IN
GEORGIA.
YOU'VE BEEN VERY CRITICAL OF
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE CLARENCE
THOMAS GIVING SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM A TEMPORARY FREEZE FROM
TESTIFYING BEFORE THAT GRAND
JURY IN GEORGIA.
WHY DO YOU THINK THOMAS'
DECISION -- WHICH, BY THE WAY,
WENT AGAINST WHAT TWO OTHER
COURTS ALREADY RULED, WHICH IS
THAT GRAHAM SHOULD HAVE TO
APPEAR BEFORE THAT GRAND JURY.
WHY DO YOU THINK THOMAS DOING
THIS IS SO EGREGIOUS?
>> IT'S EGREGIOUS BECAUSE IT'S
ILLEGAL.
IT WASN'T THE FACT THAT HE
GRANTED LINDSEY'S REQUEST, EVEN
DENYING LINDSEY'S REQUEST
WOULD'VE BEEN UNLAWFUL BECAUSE
18 U.S. CODE -- ACTUALLY 28 U.S.
CODE SECTION 455 SAYS THAT A
JUSTICE OR JUDGE, BUT IT
INCLUDES A JUSTICE, AND THE
LANGUAGE IT USES IS SHALL
DISQUALIFY HIMSELF IN ANY
PROCEEDING IN WHICH HIS
IMPARTIALITY MIGHT REASONABLY BE
QUESTIONED.
SO EVEN DENYING LINDSEY'S
REQUEST WOULD'VE BEEN WRONG.
HE SHOULD'VE JUST HANDED IT OVER
TO ANOTHER JUSTICE.
BUT THERE'S ANOTHER PART OF 28
U.S. CODE THAT IS SLAM DUNK
APPLICABLE.
IT SAYS THAT A JUSTICE SHALL --
AND I KEEP EMPHASIZING THE WORD
SHALL.
IT'S NOT DISCRETIONARY --
DISQUALIFY HIMSELF.
AND I'M GOING TO QUOTE THE
LANGUAGE, HIS SPOUSE IS KNOWN BY
THE JUSTICE TO HAVE AN INTEREST
THAT COULD BE SUBSTANTIALLY
AFFECTED BY THE OUTCOME.
NOW, WE KNOW THAT GINNI THOMAS
HAS AN INTEREST.
SHE MADE IT CLEAR, IT'S NOT EVEN
SECRET.
SHE WAS AT THE JANUARY 6th
RALLY.
SHE SENT AT LEAST 29 TEXTS A FEW
WEEKS EARLIER TO THE CHIEF OF
STAFF MARK MEADOWS URGING HIM TO
BACK UP THE PRESIDENT'S EFFORT
TO PREVENT THE TRANSFER OF POWER
TO BIDEN.
SHE SAID THE WHOLE BIDEN FAMILY
SHOULD BE TRIED FOR TREASON.
THEN THERE WERE TEXTS THAT SHE
SENT TO THE LEGISLATORS OF
ARIZONA AND WISCONSIN, URGING
THEM TO SUBMIT PHONY ELECTORAL
SLATES TO PREVENT THE TRANSFER
OF POWER.
SO SHE IS INTIMATELY INTERESTED
IN THE OUTCOME OF THE PROCEEDING
IN GEORGIA WHERE THE SAME
QUESTION, THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE AND
SENATE INCLUDING SENATOR GRAHAM
WERE ENGAGED IN AN EFFORT TO
STRONGARM PEOPLE LIKE
RAFFENSPERGER TO CREATE PHONY
VOTES.
SO SHE IS IN THE MIDDLE OF IT.
SHE HAS TO KNOW THAT.
IT'S NOT A QUESTION OF PILLOW
TALK.
EVERYONE IN THE COUNTRY KNOWS
IT.
IT'S OPEN AND SHUT.
>> AS YOU SAY, IT'S